How would you describe LLM coding tools like Cursor, Windsurf, GitHub Copilot, Cloud Code, Codex, and others having changed your dev workflow? A. It's rocket fuel. B. It's very helpful. C. It's mostly unhelpful. And D. Don't use them slash avoid them. And this is much closer to the poll that I actually cared about because for me it's rocket fuel. It's completely changed how I work. I asked on Twitter, Mastodon, LinkedIn, and YouTube. Welcome to ADSP the Podcast, Episode 244, recorded on July 1st, 2025. My name is Connor and today with my co-host, Bryce, we chat about AI, specifically AI assisted coding
你如何描述 Cursor、Windsurf、GitHub Copilot、Cloud Code、Codex 等 LLM 编码工具对你开发工作流程的改变？A. 它是火箭燃料。B. 它非常有帮助。C. 它基本没用。D. 不要使用它们/避开它们。这比我真正关心的民意调查更接近，因为对我来说，它是火箭燃料。它彻底改变了我的工作方式。我在 Twitter、Mastodon、LinkedIn 和 YouTube 上进行了询问。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客，第 244 期，录制于 2025 年 7 月 1 日。我是 Connor，今天我和我的联合主持人 Bryce 一起聊聊 AI，特别是 AI 辅助编码
tools like Cursor, Windsurf, and more. So now this is doubly a good transition because I mentioned the language app that either it's on my list of things to build, but I'm also happy for someone else to build it. And then also within that episode talking about the Kuda toolbox talk, and you've seen the demo for this, we're going to share our screen, folks, and we will make sure to walk you through this and there will be links in the show note for all of this stuff. We're going to talk about for the next hour plus, might cut it up into two episodes. We might make it all one episode, folks.
像 Cursor、Windsurf 等工具。所以现在这是一个双重好的过渡，因为我提到了那个语言应用程序，它要么在我的构建清单上，但我也很乐意让别人去构建它。然后在那一集中谈到了 Kuda 工具箱的讨论，你们已经看过这个演示了，伙计们，我们将分享我们的屏幕，我们会确保带你们了解这一切，并且所有这些东西都会在节目说明中有链接。我们将在接下来的一个多小时里讨论这个问题，可能会把它剪成两集。我们可能会把它做成一集，伙计们。
We don't know. I now have a website called it's just a subdomain off of my github.io and it is vibing projects. It's matrix themed folks and everything here is vibe coded. We I assume including the website including the website. It looks beautiful. And so the first one here is a summary of the polls. I did two polls. We're going to talk about that in a sec. But I mean, Bryce,
我们不知道。我现在有一个网站，它只是我 github.io 的一个子域名，它是 vibing projects。它是黑客帝国主题的，伙计们，这里的一切都是氛围编码的。我们，我假设包括网站，包括网站。它看起来很漂亮。所以这里的第一个是民意调查的总结。我做了两次民意调查。我们一会儿会谈到这一点。但是，Bryce，
you've seen this and it's just it makes me so happy. It's I hope the future of like the landing page for like the library ecosystem. Basically, I might even if I have the energy, which I never do, I always say that I say if I have the time and effort I'll go back and I'll find a clip, but I'm pretty sure in that episode when we were talking about this Effectively a slide from your presentation. I was like this is amazing we need to do something more with this like I pointed out that like the Rapids logo wasn't purple and You know it was hiding the kootDF and QML and friends. And so at that time I had this vision,
你已经看到了，它让我非常开心。我希望这是像库生态系统着陆页的未来。基本上，如果我有精力的话，我甚至可能会——但我从来没有——我总是说，如果我有时间和精力，我会回去找一个片段，但我很确定在那一集中，当我们谈论这个时，实际上是你演示文稿中的一张幻灯片。我说这太棒了，我们需要用它做更多的事情，比如我指出 Rapids 标志不是紫色的，你知道，它隐藏了 kootDF 和 QML 以及朋友们。所以当时我有这个愿景，
I'm not even sure how, or specifically I articulated it, but there's a chance that I basically described this and now it's here and definitely, because it wasn't in your presentation, you were the one that mentioned the categories. And so now it's all very interactive, it looks fantastic. It took me, I think. It's beautiful. A few hours.
我甚至不确定我是如何具体表达它的，但很有可能我基本上描述了这一点，现在它就在这里，而且肯定是因为它不在你的演示文稿中，你是那个提到类别的人。所以现在它非常互动，看起来棒极了。我想我花了几个小时。它很漂亮。
I mean, initially the one shot was pretty good, but it didn't look anything really close to this other than the fact it was a four by six grid. If we leave this and we come back here, we've also got a summary of the two polls. I know you saw at least one of them. I did, yeah. And the first one that I asked,
我的意思是，最初的一次性拍摄相当不错，但除了它是一个四乘六的网格之外，它看起来并不像这个。如果我们离开这里再回到这里，我们还有两个民意调查的总结。我知道你至少看到了其中一个。是的，我看到了。我问的第一个问题，
which I kind of regretted, not regretted asking, but it wasn't really the question I wanted to ask was what category best describes you about AI? Is it a maximalist? AI will transform everything rapidly and profoundly be pragmatist AI is useful, but needs careful deployment. socially harmful or D, Doomer AI poses catastrophic or existential risks. I kind of feel bad about the wording because I got AI to generate this for me. And in hindsight, you know, I think B talks about like being careful and C talks about social harms. And anyways, it wasn't the best poll, but here are the results across Twitter, Mastodon and LinkedIn. Twitter got 156 votes, Mastodon got 57, and LinkedIn got 147. Overall, if you total up the votes across the websites,
我有点后悔，不是后悔问，但那并不是我真正想问的问题，即什么类别最能描述你对 AI 的看法？它是极简主义者吗？AI 将迅速而深刻地改变一切；实用主义者，AI 很有用，但需要谨慎部署；社会有害；或者 D，末日论者，AI 构成灾难性或生存风险。我有点为措辞感到难过，因为我是让 AI 为我生成的。事后看来，你知道，我认为 B 谈论的是谨慎，而 C 谈论的是社会危害。无论如何，这不是最好的民意调查，但这是 Twitter、Mastodon 和 LinkedIn 上的结果。Twitter 获得了 156 票，Mastodon 获得了 57 票，LinkedIn 获得了 147 票。总的来说，如果你把这些网站上的票数加起来，
Maximalist for A got 7.7%, so that was the second least common. The most common was B, Pragmatist, AI is useful but needs careful deployment. That had 48.7%, so almost half of folks. Skeptic was C at 38.3% and Doomer was D at 5.2%. I got one comment, can't remember on which platform it was, but they were like, oh, you've biased the polls
极简主义者（A）获得了 7.7%，所以这是第二不常见的。最常见的是 B，实用主义者，AI 很有用，但需要谨慎部署。这占了 48.7%，几乎是一半的人。怀疑论者（C）占 38.3%，末日论者（D）占 5.2%。我收到了一条评论，不记得是在哪个平台上，但他们说，哦，你通过使用“末日论者”这个词使民意调查产生了偏见，这是带有指控性的语言。听着，好吧，我没有发明“末日论者”这个词。那是专业术语。P-Doom 是一回事，你认为奇点会发生，我们都会被消灭的概率。这是专业术语。所以不要恨玩家，要恨游戏。现在，回到你刚才说的关于民意调查的内容，民意调查的一个问题是它把两件事混为一谈了，即第一，我认为你试图问的是，AI 将被多么广泛和迅速地部署和使用？
by using the word Doomer, it's charged language. Listen, okay, I didn't come up with the term Doomer. That's the term of art. P-Doom is a thing, the probability that you think, you know, the Singularity is going to happen, we're all going to get wiped out. It's the term of art. So don't hate the player, hate the game. Now, getting to what you said earlier about the poll, the one problem with the poll is that it sort of conflates two things, which is one, how widely, like, I think what you're trying to ask about was like, how widely and rapidly will AI be deployed and useful?
相对于此，民意调查中还有第二件事混入其中，即它的风险。是的，是的，所以我事后读到它时并不是很喜欢，这就是为什么我最终发送了第二个民意调查，因为除了措辞不是最好的之外，我真心希望我只是留下了极简主义者、实用主义者、怀疑论者、末日论者，然后让人们自己推断。那可能是一个更好的民意调查。你是怎么投票的？我投了极简主义者。我非常看好 AI。这太荒谬了。我们正在看的这个网站，我基本上只是给了它民意调查的数据，我说，我想要一个静态页面，
Versus in this there's a second thing which the poll is sort of conflating into that question, which is the risk of it Yes, yes, which I so I wasn't a huge having read it in hindsight I can which is why I ended up sending a second poll because on top of it not being the best wording I honestly wish I just had a left maximalist pragmatist skeptic doomer and then let people infer what they will about it. That probably would have been a better pool. How did you vote? I voted maximalist. I'm so high on AI. It's absurd. This website we're looking at, I basically just gave it the data from the polls and I was like, I want a static page
它不必要地给了我这些饼图和环形图，但它看起来很酷。我说，给我一些漂亮的小动画之类的。如果你点击这些，它们会悬停。这一切都不是很有必要，但构建总结信息的静态页面的能力，我现在打开了吗？我昨天在 10 分钟内就构建了这个。我们有两个不同的婚礼名单，一个是来自人们回复的 Wish Joy 网站，另一个是来自我们的，你叫它什么？就像为那些想通过她预订的人处理所有预订的旅行社。
and it unnecessarily gave me these pie charts and donut charts, but it kind of looks cool. I was like, give me some nice little animations and stuff. If you click on these, they hover. It's all not really necessary, but the ability to build static pages that summarize information, do I have it open right now? I built this yesterday in like 10 minutes. We have two different wedding lists, one from this Wish Joy site that people RSVP to, and then another one from our, what do you call it? Like travel agent that did all the bookings for people that wanted to book through her.
然而，这些名单并不相同。有些人使用他们的正式或法定姓名与旅行社预订，而他们在口语中却使用其他名字，这就是他们回复时使用的名字。所以我的未婚妻 Ashima，她让我整合这些，我说，好吧，你知道，让我们找点乐子。
However, like those lists are not the same. Some people use their formal or like official legal names with the travel agent, whereas they go buy something else colloquially, which is what they used for the RSVPing. And so my fiance, Ashima, she asked me to like consolidate these and I was like, well, you know, let's have some fun.
所以我只是去问了，我说，你能帮我建一个婚礼宾客整合器吗？我有两个不同的名单。其中一些有完全匹配的名字。所以我希望你自动匹配它们，这就是这个自动匹配按钮。但在此之后，我希望能够手动点击左边的一个，右边的一个，然后让它们配对，然后把它们从这两个名单中删除。
So I just went and asked, I was like, can you build me a wedding guest like consolidator? I have two different lists. Some of them have exact name matches. So I want like you to auto match them, which is this auto match button. But then after that, I want to be able to like manually just like click on one from the left, one from the right, and then have those paired and then like remove them from both of those lists.
所以一次性拍摄基本上给了我这个看起来不同的样式。我必须问的第二个问题是，哦，请删除它们，我想它实际上已经在做了，但我只是没注意到。然后还有 Wish Joy 的回复名单。它包括每个人，包括拒绝邀请的人。所以我说，我需要一个过滤按钮，然后果然，它内置了像
And so the one shot gave me basically what this looked like with different styling. The second question I had to ask was like, oh, like, please remove them, which I think it actually was already doing, but I just I didn't notice. And then also like the the wish joy RSVS.P. list. It include everyone, including the people that declined the invitation. So I was like, I need like a filter button and then sure enough, like it built in like
导出到 CSV 的功能，只用了 10 分钟的工作就完成了。Ashima 她在医院工作。所以她现在不在城里。我像 Google，你叫它什么？Google meted。我说，亲爱的，你得看看这个。太酷了。就像你现在的能力。我像 Google，你叫它什么？Google meted。
exporting to a CSV with it like 10 minutes of work to do this. And Shima is she's doing hospital work. So she's out of town right now. I like Google. What do you call it? Google meted. I was like, sweetie, you got to look at this. It's so cool. And it's like your ability right now. I like Google, what do you call it? Google meted.
我说，亲爱的，你得看看这个。太酷了。就像你构建这些工具的能力，如果我只是跳过这一步，去用 Excel 电子表格，可能只需要多花 5 到 10 分钟的工作，因为我擅长 Excel。我本可以做到这一点，但这节省了我大约 5 到 10 分钟。这就像你拥有的力量。
I was like, sweetie, you got to look at this. It's so cool. And it's like your ability to build these tools, like probably it would have been only five or 10 minutes more work if I had just like skipped this step, gone to an Excel spreadsheet because I'm good enough with Excel. I could have done this, but this was like, it was, it saved me probably like five or 10 minutes. And it was just so much like the power that you have.
如果现在做数据的话，需要 5 到 10 分钟，所以制作 UI 不会只需要 5 到 10 分钟。哦，是的，是的，只是为了得到，归根结底我们所需要的只是来宾名单的唯一姓名列表。无论如何，你构建这种单页面的能力真是太棒了。你能确保我们回复正确吗？是的，是的。你在名单上，所以最后也有很多人回复了“是”，但没有通过旅行社预订。所以我认为有 24 个人的名单。
What would it it would have been five to ten minutes to do the data now so it wouldn't have been five to ten minutes to make a UI for it. Oh yeah yeah just to like get the all we need is like a unique list of names of the people coming at the end of the day. Anyway so just your ability to build these kind of like single page things is just phenomenal. Can you make sure we RSVP'd right? Yes yes you were on the list of folks that like so at the end of it too like there's a bunch of of like single page things is just phenomenal. Can you make sure we RSVP'd right? Yes, yes. You were on the list of folks that like, so at the end of it too, like there's a bunch of people that RSVP'd yes, but didn't book through the travel agent. So I think there was a list of 24 folks.
所以我有一个按钮，上面写着“添加自行预订的人”。然后在 CSV 中，当你导出它时，它会在括号中提到他们是自行预订的。所以我们将把它发回给我们的旅行社，还有婚礼名单的人，或者婚礼度假村的人，因为他们需要这个完整的名单。但就像你知道的，这种工具，这种工具多久会有用一次？当你只是在做事情时，在我向 Ashima 展示了这个之后，我非常兴奋，我说，选择一些东西，你想做什么？然后我们最终，如果我把它全屏模式，她必须做账单
And so then I have a button that says add people that self booked. And then in the CSV, it mentions in parentheses when you export it that they were self booked. And so then we're going to just send that back to our travel agent because And also the wedding list people or the the wedding resort folks because they need this full list But just like you know like this kind of tool how often is this kind of tool would it be useful? In when you're just doing stuff and like after when I showed a shima this I was like I was I was just so excited I was like choose something like well what do you want to do? And then we ended up, if I take this at a full screen mode, she has to do like billing
代码取决于她从事的工作类型。她在许多不同的专业领域执业。所以她是持证家庭医学医生，但她的专业是公共卫生和预防医学。但她也专门研究成瘾。所以她说，这是一个非常复杂的世界。你能帮我搜索所有的 OHIP 吗，也就是安大略省的？我其实不知道 hip 代表什么，但它就像安大略省健康卡。
codes depending on the type of work she does. And she practices in a bunch of different specialties. So she, she's a licensed family medicine doctor, but her specialty is public health and preventive medicine. But she also specializes in addiction. So she was like, it's a very complicated world. Can you just like get it to go search up all the OHIP, which is the Ontario? I actually don't know what the hip stands for, but it's like the Ontario Health Card.
我想美国人不太熟悉，但不同的国家有免费医疗，医生们会开账单。起初它列出了所有的专业。但后来她说，代码太多了，只给我我需要的四个。然后它有一些模糊搜索功能。它并不完美。有一次，她也说，哦，它在编造代码之类的。我说，好吧，是的，如果你要求它去网上搜索，如果有一个我们可以抓取的 PDF 会更好。
I guess Americans aren't familiar, but like different countries have free health care and the doctors, they they bill stuff. And so at first it came up with all the specialties. But then she was like, there's so many codes, like, just give it the four that I need. And then it has some fuzzy searching stuff. It's not perfect. And at one point, she also was like, oh, it's like it's making up codes and whatever. And I was like, well, yeah, if you're asking it to go and search online, like it'd be better if we just had like a PDF that it could scrape.
她说，哦，让我发给你 PDF。然后我们放下 PDF。她说它仍然不完美，她需要审查它。但就像她已经在寻找吸烟代码时，她说，哦，这很有趣，因为在 PDF 中它被列在社区医学下。从技术上讲，我想她说那是医院或家庭的事情，但他们把它标记为公共卫生。
She's like, oh, like, let me send you the PDF. Then we drop the PDF down. She said it's still not perfect and she needs to review it. But like already she when she was looking for like a smoking code and she was like, oh, it's interesting because in the PDF it's listed under community medicine. It technically, I think she said was a hospital or family thing, but they labeled it as public health.
所以它并不完美。但她说，但这是代码，那是价格。她说，你知道，如果我花一个小时来润色它，这会让我的生活在未来变得简单得多。她，字面上，她第一次感到如此兴奋。真的，她说，我现在明白为什么有时我很难让你去睡觉了，因为她说，我现在可以想到 20 种不同的应用程序，我可以构建
So it wasn't perfect. But she's like, but this is the code and that is the price. And she's like, you know, if I spent an hour with this polishing it, like this will make my life so much simpler going forward. And she and like literally like her excitement for the first time ever. Like truly, she's like, I now understand why sometimes I have a hard time like getting you to come to sleep because like she's like, I can now think of like 20 different applications that like I could build
像这样的东西，会让我的工作和生活变得简单得多。这很有趣，因为我也把 AI 病毒传染给了 Ramona，我们只有一个家庭 ChatGPT 订阅。所以我们使用一个账户。所以如果我去 ChatGPT，我也可以看到她所有的查询。每天都有她一直在研究的新东西。她刚买了一个新的网球拍，它打起来有点不同
something like this that would make my job and my life like so much easier. It's interesting because I also have infected Ramona with the AI bug and we only have one like family chat GPT subscription. So we're using like one account. So like if I go to chat GPT, I can see like all of her queries too. And like every day there's a new thing that she's been researching. She just got a new tennis racket and it hits a little bit different
比她旧的网球拍。所以她一直在使用 AI 来制定她可以使用的训练计划。她说，我想要一些，这是一个我可以打印出来的 PDF。它有一个课程计划。我甚至不需要鼓励她那么多。我向她展示了它，我向她展示了如何
than her old tennis racket. And so she's been using AI to come up with a training plan that she could use. And she was like, I want some, it's a PDF that I can print out. It's got a lesson plan. And I didn't even have to like encourage her that much. Like I showed it to her, I showed her like how
在几个月前开始使用 AI 工具，现在她把它用于令人惊讶的许多事情。她只是在使用 ChatGPT 界面吗？因为我不知道它可以生成 PDF，还是说你帮她连接了？不，不，不。是的，ChatGPT 可以生成 PDF，可以生成几乎任何文件类型，就像你要求它提供 Excel 文件、PDF 或一大堆东西一样，是的，它可以做很多事情。我想它能做，我的意思是，我猜至少在某些情况下，它生成 PDF 的方式是因为它有 Python 脚本环境，所以它可能只是运行 Python
to start using AI tools like a couple months ago and now she uses it for like a surprising number of things. Is she using just the chat GPT interface? Because I didn't know it could generate PDFs or you're saying that you hooked her up with? No, no, no. Yeah, chat GPT can can generate PDFs can generate almost any file type like you ask it for like an Excel file for PDF for a whole bunch of things yeah it can do a lot of that I think I think it does I mean I would guess that at least in some cases the way it's gonna do the PDF generation is because it has it has its Python scripting environment so it may just it may just like run Python could
生成 PDF。但我认为它有一个用于 PDF 生成的原生工具。但对于其他一些文件格式和脚本任务，如果你正在使用推理模式并查看推理跟踪，你会看到它正在调用一个工具来完成工作。对，对。是的，我的意思是，Ashima 非常兴奋。
generate the PDF. But I think it has a native tool for PDF generation. But for some other file formats and for some scripting tasks, you'll see if you're using the reasoning mode and you look at the reasoning trace, you'll see that it's calling out to a tool to do the work. Right, right. Yeah, I mean, Shima is so excited.
她基本上说，我需要访问它，因为我正在使用 Cursor 和 Cloud 4。她说，我太兴奋了。她基本上说，我需要访问它，因为我正在使用 Cursor 和 Cloud 4。是的。她说，我需要，我现在就需要这个，因为当我们在构建这个时，我向她展示了我所做的只是用英语交谈，我喜欢这是 HTML、CSS。我不是，我不是 Web 开发人员。你知道，如果我需要修复某些东西，因为模型无法弄清楚，我知道得足够多。但这些天，它从来没有，如果它弄乱了一些对齐，你只需要说，哦，嘿，抱歉，当你展开饼图时，它稍微超出了边界，
She basically was like, I need access to it, because I'm using Cursor in Cloud 4. And she's like, I need so excited. She basically was like, I need access to because I'm using cursor in cloud four. Yeah. And she's like, I need I need this now because she when we were building this, like I showed her that all I do is talk in English and I like this is HTML, CSS. I'm not I'm not a web dev. You know, I know enough if I need to fix something because the model can't figure it out. But like these days, it never if it messes up some alignment, you just say, oh, hey, sorry, the pie chart when you expand it is slightly outside the border some alignment you just say oh hey sorry the the pie
你只需要说，哦，嘿，抱歉，当你展开饼图时，它稍微超出了边界，你能修复一下吗？你甚至不需要说，我知道你想说的是增加内边距，这样它就不会那样做了，但你可以只用英语，我真的认为我告诉她，你需要知道这一层东西，你需要知道命令行，你需要知道 git，如果你想在某个网站上托管某些东西，然后你需要知道，有一次她想要某种颜色，然后她说，哦，是这种颜色。我说，好吧，你能给我那个的十六进制代码吗？就像，
chart when you expand it is slightly outside the border could you just like fix that you don't have to even say like I know that what you want to say is increase the padding so that it doesn't do that but like you can just use English and and I really think I was telling her that like there's this layer of stuff that you need to know like you need to know command line you need to know get if you want to host something on some website and then you need to know like at one point she wanted a certain color and then she's like, oh, it's this color. And I was like, well, can you give me the hex code for that? Like,
你知道，它会，它会，我们还没有达到你可以直接把截图放到文件夹里，然后它就能从那里弄清楚颜色的地步。好吧，我的意思是，我试过了。我试过了。所以，在某个时候我们会达到那个地步。但目前在这个时间点，你需要知道的东西只有薄薄的一层，比如，如果你想托管一个网站，你只需要在某个 GitHub 仓库的根目录下放一个 index.html。我可以在一小时内教她这些东西。而且，她只需要知道，当模型告诉她它不能做某事时，让它们为你写一个 Python 脚本。
you know, it'll it'll it'll we're not at the point where you can just drop a screenshot in a folder and then it can like, you know, figure out the color from that. Well, I mean, I tried it. I tried it. So like, it were at some point we will get there. But like currently at this point in time, like like, there's such a thin layer of stuff that you need to know in terms of, like, you know, if you're trying to host some website, you just, like, put an index.html at the root of some GitHub repo. I could teach her that stuff in, like, an hour. And, like, all she needs to know is, like, when a model tells her that it can't do something, ask them to write a Python script for you.
就像如果它说，哦，我不能去抓取这些东西，就像，好吧，那就给我一个可以抓取的 Python 脚本，因为用 Python 你能做的事情没有限制，Python 可以做任何事情。所以，无论如何，回到民意调查。所以我们的合作伙伴很有效率，这很好。我有一个关于诊断代码的问题。
Like if it says, oh, I can't go and like scrape this stuff, it's like, okay, well just give me a Python script that can because there's no limitation on what you can do with Python and Python can do anything. And so it's just like, you know, anyways, to get back to the poll. So it's good that our partners are effective. I have a question about the diagnostic code.
查找东西，你能回到那个吗？诊断代码。是的，是的。抱歉，我只是。OHIP 账单那个。查找东西，你能回到那个吗？诊断代码？是的，是的。抱歉，我只是想谈谈我的……OHIP 账单那个。抱歉，我听不清你在说什么。你是说账单那些东西吗？是的，是的，是的。
Look up thing, can you go back to that one? The diagnostic code. Yeah, yeah. Sorry, I just. The OHIP billing one. Look up thing, can you go back to that one? The diagnostic code? Yeah, yeah. Sorry, I just wanted to talk about my... The OHIP billing one. Sorry, I can't hear what you're saying. Do you mean the billing stuff? Yeah, yeah, yeah.
所以，好吧，我的问题是你的数据源是什么？数据源是有一个 PDF 你喂给它，然后它只是把关于 PDF 的信息嵌入到这个中。这就像一个静态页面。是的，所以这些都是静态 HTML 页面。最初，我们只是说，
So, okay, so my question was gonna be what is your data source here? The data source is that there was some PDF that you fed it in and then it just embeds the information about the PDF into this. This is just like a static page. Yeah, so all of these are just static HTML pages. Initially, we just said,
你能去获取所有不同专业的 OHIP 代码吗？然后我们给了它一个例子，比如 957 之类的。但很快，Ashima 就说，好吧，它漏掉了很多，那个不存在。所以，我不知道这里发生了什么。然后我提到了 PDF 的事情，Ashima 说，好吧，它漏掉了很多。那个不存在。所以，我不知道这里发生了什么。然后我提到了 PDF 的事情。
can you go get the OHIP codes for all the different specialties? And then we gave it one example of like a, I don't know, 957 or something like that. But then very quickly, Shima was like, well, it's missing a bunch, that one doesn't exist. So like, I don't know what's going on here. And then I mentioned the PDF thing Shima was like, well, it's missing a bunch. That one doesn't exist. So I don't know what's going on here. And then I mentioned the PDF thing.
她说，哦，然后她把它扔进了 WhatsApp，我下载了它。然后她说，好的，这好多了。所以是的，这是一个 PDF。我其实以为它会构建一个 Python 脚本来抓取它。但显然，它知道我的 Ubuntu 机器上有一个叫 PDF2Text 的工具，它直接调用了它，它
And she's like, oh, and then she dropped it into WhatsApp, and I downloaded it. And then she was like, OK, this is way better. So yeah, it was a PDF. I actually thought it was going to build a Python script to scrape it. But apparently, it knew about some tool called PDF2Text on my Ubuntu machine that it just called directly and it
就像一个，我甚至不认为那是光学字符识别，我认为它字面上只是，它只是从 PDF 文件中提取了原始文本，所以从那里它用那些东西做了一些事情。我想知道，如果你想把它与实时数据源集成，这会有多大的挑战。我的意思是，我不知道。我想我会那样做。
was like a I don't even think it was optical character recognition I think it was literally just like it just took the raw text out of the PDF file and so then from there it did something with that stuff. I wonder whether like I wonder how much more challenging this would be if if you wanted to like integrate it with a live data source. I mean, I don't know. I guess I would do that.
我的意思是，这些代码不会改变。好吧，它们不会那么频繁地改变，是的。是的。我的意思是，我假设。但这会解决准确性问题。如果有一些在线地方列出了所有这些代码，但不是以可搜索的方式，那么你就可以告诉它，直接从这里获取数据。只要有一些 JavaScript 东西去获取这个
I mean, these codes don't change. Okay, they don't change that frequently, yeah. Yeah. I mean, I'm assuming. But it would fix the accuracy problem. If there was some online place that lists all these codes, but not in a searchable way, then you could just tell it, just get the data from here. Just have some JavaScript thing that goes and fetches this
并导入它。我想在医疗记录系统的陈旧世界里，他们没有 API 端点，你可以去获取一个包含所有这些东西的 JSON 对象。我猜，我认为这就是为什么这是她想到的第一件事。她说，好吧，比较棘手的事情之一
and imports it. I imagine in the antiquated world of medical record systems, they do not have some API endpoint that you can go ahead and get a JSON object with all this stuff. I'm guessing that, and I think that's why this was the first thing that came to mind for her. She's like, well, one of the trickier things
是大多数人只在一个专业领域工作。他们作为家庭医生专业化，这就是他们执业的全部。但因为她，她的专业是公共卫生和预防医学，你五年住院医师的前两年是家庭医学。所以一开始，你基本上就成为了一名家庭医生。
is like most people, they only operate in one specialty. Like they specialize as a family doctor and that's all they practice. But because she, her specialty was public health and preventive medicine, the first two years of your five year residency is in family medicine. So right off the bat, you basically become a family doctor.
然后她做了公共卫生，但后来她做了一个专业化。所以她在执业。而且她还作为医院医生进行远程医院工作。这就是她现在正在做的事情。所以她在四个专业领域工作。她说，有时我工作在医院工作不如我工作在成瘾工作那么频繁。所以，我不熟悉这些代码。而且，
Then she did public health, but then she did a specialization. So she's operating. And then she also practices as a hospitalist doing remote hospital work. That's what she's doing right now. So she operates across four specialties. And she's like, sometimes I don't work in the hospital work as frequently as I work in addiction work. So like, I'm not as familiar with the codes. And like,
你真的需要知道你的代码才能正确开账单。这就像最重要的部分之一。所以，她正确地完成了所有的账单，但这只是一个痛苦。我假设她递给我 PDF 的事实是，这就是她在查看这个列出每个专业和所有这些不同代码的大型 PDF 时所寻找的，而实际上她知道有一些吸烟账单代码或一些，其他代码之一是什么，比如咨询。所以你只需要输入 C-O-U-N，所有在描述中提到咨询的不同个人咨询
you really need to know your codes in order to build properly. It's like one of the most important parts. And so like, she does all the billing correctly, but it's just like a pain. And I'm assuming the fact that she handed me the PDF is like, that's what she's she's looking up in like this large PDF that lists every single specialty and all these different codes when really she knows that there's some smoking billing code or some, what was one of the other ones, like counseling. So you just type in C-O-U-N and all the different individual counseling
或事情，它们就会立即显示出来。她说，这就是我需要的。我只需要一些可以过滤掉我关心的所有不同代码和专业的东西，看看账单代码是什么。而且，你知道，这就是你听到的，这有点像我们正在掩盖这个的重点。
or things that mention counseling in the description, they just immediately show up. She's like, this is what I need. I just need something that can filter out across all the different codes and specialties that I care about what the billing codes are. And it's like, you know, and that's you hear, which is kind of what we're we're burying the lead of this.
你知道，你和我对这项技术都非常看好。是的。但当我们谈到 AI 民意调查时，所以我问的第二个民意调查，这实际上更接近我关心的针对开发者的民意调查。你如何描述 Cursor、Windsurf、GitHub Copilot、Cloud Code、Codex 等 LLM 编码工具对你开发工作流程的改变？A，它是火箭燃料。B，它非常有帮助。C，它基本没用。
You know, both of you and I are very high on this technology. Yeah. But when we go to the AI poll, so the second poll that I asked, which was actually closer to what I cared about a poll for devs. How would you describe LLM coding tools like Cursor, Windsurf, GitHub Copilot, Cloud Code, Codex, and others having changed your dev workflow? A, it's rocket fuel. B, it's very helpful. C, it's mostly unhelpful.
D，不要使用它们/避开它们。这比我真正关心的民意调查更接近，因为我，对我来说，它是火箭燃料。它彻底改变了我的工作方式，如果你看整体，这个我实际上，所以我问了 Twitter、Mastodon、LinkedIn 和 YouTube，这只持续了 24 小时，所以它不像另一个那么长，Twitter 上 55 票，Mastodon 上 9 票，LinkedIn 上 78 票，YouTube 上 120 票，平均排名第一的答案是不要使用它们，避开它们，占 35.7%。
And D, don't use them slash avoid them. And this is much closer to the poll that I actually cared about because I, for me, it's rocket fuel. It's completely changed, you how I work and if you look at the overall and this one I actually so I asked on Twitter Macedon LinkedIn and YouTube this only lasted 24 hours So it wasn't as long as the other one 55 votes on Twitter 9 on Macedon 78 on LinkedIn and 120 on YouTube the number one answer Averaged was don't use them, avoid them at 35.7%.
它与 B 和 C 相当，即无用和有用，分别为 24.4% 和 32.5%。但最后一名是 7.4%。有点意思。我知道 Mastodon 是一个较小的集合大小。另一个民意调查也是如此，Mastodon 的结果与其他结果非常不同。非常，非常不同。78% 的人不要使用/避开它们。就像 LinkedIn 和 YouTube 也不同，
It's pretty even with BNC, which is unhelpful and helpful at 24.4% and 32.5%. But in last place by a long shot is 7.4%. Kind of interesting. I know Mastodon is a smaller set size. With the other poll too, where the Mastodon results were very different than the other results. Very, very different. It's 78% don't use avoid them. Like LinkedIn and YouTube are also different,
但我注意到 Mastodon 结果的一点是，无论是在这里还是在另一个民意调查中，Mastodon 的结果对一个观点有非常极端的偏向。是的，所以 Mastodon 似乎最反 AI，无论你对它的定义是什么。但无论如何，这就是背景，就像我发布了两个较短的剧集，指向人们其他 AI 内容、播客、文章。
but the thing I noticed about the Mastodon results both here and the other poll was that the Mastodon results have a very extreme skew to one perspective. Yes, so Mastodon seems to be anti-AI the most for whatever your definition of that is. But anyway, so this is the backdrop of like I released two shorter episodes pointing people to other AI content, podcasts, articles.
其中一篇文章是“我所有的 AI 怀疑论者朋友都是疯子”，我觉得这太棒了。这就是我得到“啜饮火箭燃料”这些术语的地方，他还提到了 Claude 中毒的开发者。我不一定喜欢“中毒”这个词，因为它有负面含义，但它听起来比“Claude 超级充电”或“Claude 开明”要好，但我绝对是，如果这个词是 Claude 中毒，我就是超级 Claude 中毒。而且我，是的，我想和你谈谈，我想和其他人谈谈，就像我刚刚在我的播客订阅源中看到的那样，当所有的开发工作都消失或 AI 取代了我们所有的工作时会发生什么。
One of the articles was all my AI skeptic friends are nuts, which I thought was fantastic. It's where I've gotten the terms sipping rocket fuel and he also refers to Claude poison devs. I don't necessarily like the word poison because it's got a negative connotation But I it sounds better than like Claude supercharged or Claude enlightened But I definitely am like if it's if the word is Claude poisoned. I am super Claude poisoned And I I yeah, I want to talk to you and I want to talk to other folks Like I just saw on my podcast feed what happens when all the dev jobs are gone or AI takes all our jobs.
它来自 Co Recursive 播客。关于这些东西是好是坏，它们是否有用，没用，有很多讨论。无论如何，这就是我只想聊聊的，就像还有另一个由 Primogen 和朋友们制作的播客。他们有四个人，TJ、Dax 和 Casey 之类的，Casey 说他使用它们的比例是 0%，然后其他人从 40% 到 80% 不等，而且
And it was from the co recursive podcast. And there's a ton of discourse around like whether these things are good. They're bad. They're useful. Not useful. And anyways that's what I just want to chat like how there was another podcast by the primogen and friends guys. There's like four of them TJ Dax and Casey something and Casey he said he was using them 0% and then the other ones were anywhere from like 40% to 80% and
无论如何，我只是，我非常震惊人们怎么能发现没有用处。如果你的论点是它对地球有害，而且我不同意版权等的法律影响，好吧，公平地说。但实用性，我认为它比互联网更改变生活。它彻底改变了我的工作方式。它将改变所有这些职业
Anyways, I'm just like I'm I am so flabbergasted on how people can find no utility. If your argument is that it's bad for the planet and I disagree with the legal implications of copyright and whatnot, OK, fair enough. But the utility, I think it's more life-changing than the internet. It's completely changed the way I work. It's going to be changing the way that all these professions
的工作方式，在我看来。无论如何，我很好奇你的想法，我想听众可能已经听够了我的话。你有什么想法？你在你日常工作的人中看到了什么，因为你比我接触更多的人，比如在研究方面。所以，是的，交给你了。是的，所以，我的意思是，让我们先谈谈，AI 是不是要来抢所有人的工作？让我们先谈谈，AI 是不是要来抢所有人的工作？你知道，我不确定我们之前在播客中是否使用过这个类比，我不这么认为。
are working, in my opinion. Anyways, I'm curious to get your thoughts I think probably the listeners have heard enough from me. What are your thoughts? What have you seen amongst like the people that you're Working with on a day-to-day basis because you interact with more folks than I do like on on research. So yeah over to you Yeah, so I mean Let's first talk about the is it is AI come in for everyone's jobs Let's first talk about the, is AI coming for everyone's jobs? You know, I'm not sure if we've used this analogy before in the podcast, I don't think so.
但在 1980 年代，第一款电子表格软件出现了，比如 VisiCalc 和 Lotus 123。我认为那是第一款，或者至少它们是第一款在商业上可行的。会计行业陷入了恐慌。他们说，哦，以后不会再有会计师了。20、30 年后，将不会有会计师
But in the 1980s, the first spreadsheet software came out like VisiCalc and Lotus 123. I think those were the first, or at least they were the first to be commercially viable. And the accounting industry was in a panic. They were like, oh, there's going to be no more accountants. 20, 30 years from now, there will be no accountants
因为电子表格会扼杀会计。我的意思是，这显然是不正确的。发生的一切只是会计变得不那么乏味了。而且，你知道，在你有电子表格软件之前，在你拥有会计软件之前，会计师只有账本，他们有纸，一切都在纸上，你回去看这些照片，会计师会创建这些巨大的，
because the spreadsheet will kill accounting. And I mean, that's obviously not true. All that's happened is that accounting has become less tedious. And, you know, it used to be like before before you had spreadsheet software, and before you had like accounting software, accountants would just have books, they would have paper, everything would be on paper, you go back and you look at these pictures, where accountants would create these huge,
巨大的物理表格。你会有一个巨大的桌子，上面有一张物理表格，你可以在上面做所有的会计工作。你会像在电子表格中一样有单元格、行和列。这就是你做所有会计工作的方式。这太糟糕了。它非常乏味，而且更容易出错。然后电子表格软件出现了。它没有扼杀会计行业。
huge like physical sheets. You'd have a huge table where you'd have a physical sheet where you'd do all the accounting. You'd have cells, you know, rows and columns just like you would in a spreadsheet. And that's how you would do all the accounting work. And it was like awful. It was incredibly tedious and like a lot more mistake prone. And then spreadsheet software came out. And it didn't kill the accounting industry.
它只是改变了它。我的意思是，仍然有很多会计师。我不知道现在会计师是否比以前少了。但会计师并没有消失。这并不是一个正在消亡的行业。精算师也是如此，对吧？
It just changed it. I mean, there are still plenty of accountants. I don't know whether there's maybe fewer accountants now than there used to be. But it's not like accountants now than there used to be, but it's not like accountants are going away. It's not like it's an industry that's dying. The same for actuaries, right?
就像电子表格和其他计算机软件的发明，精算师今天都在使用，并没有让这个领域消失，只是改变了它。它使工人更有效率，老实说，我认为它使生活质量好多了，因为我认为如果你在 70 年代和 80 年代是一名会计师，你弯腰在这个桌子上，在纸上填写东西，我认为你会更乐意在软件中做这件事。所以我不认为软件工程会消失。我认为这个领域会改变。每次，我认为，在经济史上
Like the invention of spreadsheets and of other computer software that actuaries now all use today did not make the field go away, just changed it. It made workers more efficient and I honestly I think it made quality of life a lot better because I think if you were an accountant in like the 70s and 80s and you were leaning over this table like filling in you know stuff on this paper I think you'd be a lot happier to like be doing it in software. So I don't think that software engineering is going to go away. I think that the field's going to change. Every time, I think, in the history of economics
我们看到了效率的巨大提高，我们看到了行业的变化，但不是像，有几个例外，比如农业，你知道，过去劳动力中有很大一部分在农场工作，或者我想在 1880 年代，我前几天读了一篇文章，我想美国 30% 的 GDP 是木柴的生产销售。这显然不再是这种情况了。但我认为通常每次我们看到生产力和效率的巨大提高时，我们都会看到人们的生活质量得到改善。而且我不认为我们处于一个
that we've seen great increases in efficiency, we've seen industries change, but not like, there's a couple exceptions like you know agriculture you know there used to be like a large percentage of the workforce was you know worked on a farm or I think in like I read an article the other day like in the 1880s I think it was that like 30% of the United States GDP was the production sale of firewood. That's obviously no longer the case. But I think generally every time we've seen great increases in productivity and efficiency, we've seen quality of life improve for people. And I don't think we're at a point where
而且我不认为我们处于一个我们将生活在某种乌托邦社会中，我们根本不需要人类参与工作的地步。所以是的，我不认为我们所有的工作很快就会消失。虽然它们的性质可能会改变。我确实想知道你的会计故事或历史回顾中是否有一个类比，因为我确实认为有很多行业，包括软件，存在着不同层次的工作。你知道，有高级工程师，有初级工程师，特别是如果你是一名初级工程师，正在构建这些 SPA 单页面应用程序，而且它只是 HTML 和 CSS
And I don't think like we're at a point where like we're gonna live in some Utopian society where we don't need to have humans involved in like work at all So yeah, I don't think that I don't think that all of our jobs are going away anytime soon They may change though in their nature. I do wonder if there's an analogy though in your accountant story or a recap of history in that I do think that there are a lot of industries including software where there are kind of levels of work. You know there's the senior engineer and there's the junior engineer and specifically if you're a junior engineer that's building these you know spas single page applications and like it's just HTML and CSS
我想到的第一个是律师和律师助理，律师助理正在做这种，所以我很好奇在过去的会计行业，是否有 CPA 会计师，然后还有其他工作会做某种手动之类的，我确实认为很多这样的工作将会消失，因为如果你只是为了花哨的 JavaScript D3 动画，无论什么，你不需要雇佣 Web 开发人员。我相信 ChatGPT 可以帮助你，但它不是
and the other ones I think about the first one that comes to mind is like there's lawyers and then there's paralegals and the paralegals are doing this kind of and so I wonder in the accounting industry back in the day was there like you know the CPA accountants and then like some other job that would like do some kind of manual whatever and I do think that like a lot of those jobs are going to vanish because you don't need to hire a web dev person if you're just for the fancy JavaScript D3 animated, beautiful, whatever. I'm sure Chad GPT can help you, but it's not
那些面包和黄油的东西，他们可以在 10 秒内敲出一个。所以我确实认为有一些影响，我很好奇过去是否发生过类似的事情，但它只是在历史的编年史中被遗忘了。因为我不知道，我保证有很多听众会说
the stuff that is the bread and butter that they can knock out one of these in 10 seconds. So I do think that there is some impact and I wonder if similar things have happened in the past but it's just like, it kind of gets forgotten in the annals of history. And cause I don't know, I guarantee you that there's a bunch of listeners being like
这并不完全只是雇佣了一堆会计师，他们改变了工作方式。因为现在，有很多软件工程师被雇佣，他们现在使用这些工具的效率提高了 10 倍、100 倍，他们不需要雇佣初级开发人员，所以现在一个小团队可以用更少的人力资源完成更多的工作。所以是的，我不知道你对此有什么回应。我确实认为，你知道，变化意味着今天存在的一些工作将不会继续存在。
it's not exactly just that like a bunch of accountants were employed and they changed the way they worked. Cause now it's like, there's a bunch of software engineers that are employed that are now like 10 times, a 100 times more productive with these tools and they don't need to hire junior devs and so now like a small team can get done a lot more with a lot less like human resources. So yeah I don't know what your response to that is. I do think that you know change means that some number of jobs that exist today will not continue to exist.
但我认为软件行业将继续存在并蓬勃发展。我想也许工作岗位会减少，但我不认为会有一个数量级的下降。所以经济学中有一个原则，我不记得名字了，但基本上这个原则的关键是，当某样东西的成本显著下降时，你往往会看到使用量的巨大增加。这出现在几个月前关于 DeepSeq 模型的恐慌中，当时他们说，哦，DeepSeq，他们训练了一个新的、更便宜的模型。
But I think that the software industry will continue to exist and thrive. And I think maybe there will be fewer jobs, but I don't think it's going to be a decrease in order of magnitude. And so there's a principle in economics, I can't remember the name, but basically the key of the principle is that when the cost of something drops significantly, you tend to see great increase in usage. This came up when there was all the scare about the DeepSeq model a couple months ago where they're like, oh, DeepSeq, they trained a new, cheaper model.
但我认为软件行业将继续存在并蓬勃发展。我认为工作岗位可能会减少，但我不认为会呈数量级下降。经济学中有一个原理，我不记得名字了，但这个原理的核心基本上是，当某样东西的成本大幅下降时，其使用量往往会大幅增加。几个月前关于DeepSeq模型的恐慌出现时就提到了这一点，当时人们说，哦，DeepSeq，他们训练了一个新的、更便宜的模型。
And does that mean that the whole AI industry is going to go bust? And the answer is no. If the cost of training and deploying and using AI models goes down by 100x, that's going to mean that there's actually going to be more usage of AI because it will be more affordable. In the case of like a web dev, I think if you want to have a website built today, if
这是否意味着整个AI行业都要破产了？答案是否定的。如果训练、部署和使用AI模型的成本降低100倍，这意味着AI的使用量实际上会增加，因为它变得更负担得起了。以网页开发为例，我认为如果你今天想建一个网站，如果你
you're like a company, you want to have a website built today, like a simple website, I think it's like 5 to 10k. And there's a lot of businesses out there that still don't have great websites. In particular, within the US, it's pretty common for companies to have a website. You go and travel overseas, a lot of countries do not have websites for things. This always bothers Ramona. She loves playing tennis. Every time we travel, she wants to go find a local tennis club, they never have websites.
是一家公司，你想建一个网站，比如一个简单的网站，我认为费用大概在5000到1万美元之间。市面上有很多企业仍然没有像样的网站。特别是在美国，公司拥有网站是很普遍的。你去海外旅行时，很多国家的企业根本没有网站。这总是让Ramona很困扰。她喜欢打网球。每次我们旅行，她想找当地的网球俱乐部时，他们从来都没有网站。
Like, we're in the middle of nowhere in Austria or we're in Turkey or we're in Bulgaria and she can find on Google Maps like a tennis club and maybe they have a phone number but they don't have a website that has the details about how to contact them, et cetera, et cetera. And so if the cost of getting a website developed by a web dev drops from like 5 to 10k down to like $100 to $500, because now the web dev, instead of them having to spend like a week or two doing this thing, they can just feed it into an LOM. They can pop out like 10 times or 100 times more websites a year, and the maintenance
比如，我们在奥地利、土耳其或保加利亚的偏僻地方，她能在谷歌地图上找到网球俱乐部，也许他们有一个电话号码，但他们没有一个包含联系方式等详细信息的网站。所以，如果由网页开发人员制作网站的成本从5000到1万美元降到100到500美元，因为现在开发人员不需要花一两周时间做这件事，他们可以直接将其输入大语言模型。他们一年可以多产出10倍甚至100倍的网站，维护
burden also decreases for them. Then they can drop their prices. And then I think that means that a lot more companies, a lot more small businesses, a lot more organizations will have websites. A lot more things will become digitized. And I think if you look at the world and usage of technology in the world, there's still like a very long tail of the world that's not digitized. And, you know, processes that aren't automated, that aren't, you know, handled in software, tracked in software, companies that don't have websites, etc.
负担对他们来说也降低了。那么他们就可以降低价格。我认为这意味着会有更多的公司、更多的小企业、更多的组织拥有网站。更多的事情将实现数字化。我认为如果你审视这个世界以及全球对技术的使用，世界上仍然有很长的一条尾部尚未数字化。你知道，那些没有自动化、没有在软件中处理、没有在软件中跟踪的流程，那些没有网站的公司等等。
There's still a really long tail of that. The total market for tech stuff is much larger than the currently realized market. So I think that if you're a web dev, you probably should start using AI and probably the change that's gonna happen is that your costs are gonna go down and that's gonna mean that you're gonna need to find, you're gonna have to figure out how to bring in more customers and your business
这方面仍然有很长的尾部。科技产品的总市场远大于目前已实现的市场。所以我认为，如果你是一名网页开发人员，你可能应该开始使用AI，可能即将发生的变化是你的成本会降低，这意味着你需要找到并弄清楚如何吸引更多的客户，你的业务
is going to be more of a volume business. You need to find a way to automate more of your business to be able to survive in this new world. Do you think this is the key reason behind the polls and kind of the don't avoid or use or you don't find it that helpful is that there's a bunch of folks that are worried about the impact It's gonna have on like our industry Yeah, I Think so, but I also I mean
将更多地成为一种量产型业务。你需要找到一种方法来自动化更多的业务，以便在这个新世界中生存。你认为这是人们对AI持观望态度，或者说不使用、觉得没那么有用的关键原因吗？是因为有一群人担心它会对我们的行业产生影响吗？是的，我想是这样，但我也……我的意思是
one one of one of the like, you know Bryce's laws is that like inertia is king and in the software industry you know the the almost always the reason that we in the software industry. Almost always the reason that we make decisions in software is around inertia. Usually like when we're making like poor decisions. There's a lot of people talking about in the AI space that like distribution is king, right?
布莱斯定律（Bryce's laws）之一就是惯性为王。在软件行业，你知道，几乎总是因为惯性，我们才在软件行业做出决策。通常当我们做出糟糕的决策时也是如此。AI领域有很多人在谈论分发（distribution）为王，对吧？
The distribution is the key thing. Like if you have distribution,, that's your moat. And I think that that sort of gets to the point here that if you're able, if you've got a captive audience, if you've got users already, even if you're just an AI, even if you're just wrapping some frontier models, the hard part is not developing. Developing the models is hard but
分发是关键。如果你拥有分发渠道，那就是你的护城河。我认为这触及了重点：如果你能拥有一个固定的受众，如果你已经拥有了用户，即使你只是一个AI，即使你只是在封装一些前沿模型，困难的部分不在于开发。开发模型很难，但是
There's always going to be a new you know Great model, you know coming out, you know, six months from now, right? That's going to disrupt the the field and The thing that really gives you long-term survivability is if you've got a customer base that's already bought into using your thing. Because for them to switch away from using your thing, the other thing that has to be 10x better. The OpenAI doesn't have to have the best models. Because we use chat GPT as a verb, right?
总会有新的、伟大的模型在六个月后出现，对吧？那将会颠覆这个领域。真正能让你长期生存的是你拥有一个已经习惯使用你产品的客户群。因为要让他们放弃使用你的产品，另一个产品必须好上10倍。OpenAI不一定非要有最好的模型。因为我们已经把“ChatGPT”当作动词来用了，对吧？
Like, oh, if you're gonna use a large language model for something, somebody says like, oh, I'm gonna go chat GPT this. Because it was the first on the scene, that's gotta be by far the most popular place where people go to interact with a model, with a large language model. And so they've got a huge moat because of that. They don't have to a large language model. And so like they've got a huge moat because of that.
比如，如果你要用大语言模型做某事，有人会说：“哦，我要去ChatGPT一下这个。”因为它是最早出现的，所以它必然是人们去与模型、与大语言模型交互的最受欢迎的地方。因此，他们拥有巨大的护城河。他们不需要……他们拥有巨大的护城河。
Like they don't have to have the best model. And I think that, you know, for many, many years I just used like them and VI. Like I wouldn't use an IDE. Like I learned my ways of doing things. I didn't want to change, right? like I was happy with how I was doing things Change would require work would require me to stop what I'm doing and spend some time to set up a new thing And so I was resistant to the change just because like I was doing something that was working
他们不需要拥有最好的模型。我认为，很多很多年来，我只是使用像Vim这样的工具。我不会使用IDE。我习惯了我的做事方式。我不想改变，对吧？我对自己的做事方式很满意。改变需要工作，需要我停下手中的事情，花时间去设置一个新东西。所以我抵制改变，仅仅是因为我正在做的事情是有效的。
I didn't want to go and you know change change how I was working. I think that's the way for a lot of engineers So I think it's I think it's the way for a lot of engineers. So I think it's, I'm sure some of it is people being afraid of it. And some part of it, I think, is people not trusting it. People thinking, oh, it's not going to be good enough. That's a piece of it, too. It would be interesting to know from those people who
我不想去改变我的工作方式。我认为很多工程师都是这样。所以我认为，我肯定其中一部分原因是人们对它感到恐惧。而另一部分原因，我认为是人们不信任它。人们认为，哦，它不够好。这也是其中的一部分。如果能从那些
said that they don't use AI how many people have tried it. How many people have tried it and Then gotten frustrated and decide to not continue because it is certainly a frustrating experience. I've had frustrating experiences using cursor Both on the like the model doing dumb thing is I've had like times where like cursor has been buggy You know all sorts of things like that. And you know, it took me a couple days to like learn how to use it effectively. And there were certainly times where I sort of got into like a rabbit,
说他们不使用AI的人那里了解有多少人尝试过，那会很有趣。有多少人尝试过，然后感到沮丧并决定不再继续，因为这确实是一种令人沮丧的体验。我在使用Cursor时也有过令人沮丧的经历，既有模型做蠢事的时候，也有Cursor本身出现Bug的时候，你知道，各种各样的事情。而且，我花了好几天才学会如何有效地使用它。确实有几次我陷入了……
like went down a rabbit hole of like, oh, I'm asking it to do this thing. It's just not doing it correctly. And instead of me just going to do it manually, I'm just like I'm gonna keep hammering on this thing and yelling at this model until it does what I want because I'm very frustrated and like it should be able to do what I want. And so I wonder if some part of it is people have tried and run into some of the limitations and then decided like oh well it has limitations and then decided like, oh, well, it has limitations. And so because I was already skeptical, I'm just going to assume it's not good enough.
陷入了死胡同，比如，我让它做这件事，它就是做不对。与其我手动去做，我反而会一直敲打这个东西，对这个模型大喊大叫，直到它做我想要的事情，因为我非常沮丧，而且它应该能够做到我想要的。所以我怀疑其中一部分原因是人们尝试过并遇到了一些局限性，然后决定：“哦，好吧，它有局限性。”因为我本来就持怀疑态度，所以我只会假设它不够好。
And that may be part of it. But I think a large part of it is just inertia. It's just people haven't tried it because it's hard to get people to try new things. Yeah, I will say, I mean, I think we've all been there if you're using these tools, is it definitely you can end up in these rabbit holes? And I guess, I mean, one of the thoughts that when you were saying that is that
这可能是原因的一部分。但我认为很大一部分原因只是惯性。只是人们还没有尝试过，因为让人们尝试新事物很难。是的，我会说，我的意思是，我想如果我们都在使用这些工具，肯定会陷入这些死胡同。我想，当你这么说的时候，我产生的一个想法是
I wonder if a part of my maximalism on these tools is that I am an expert in C++ and it's already such a painful experience like half the time. And like I'm an expert but just sometimes you run into some like if you're doing bleeding it cutting edge stuff with like template metaprogramming or constexpr metaprogramming it's just like the errors are awful and like it is literally like there are talks by like Vittorio Romeo and friends of like tools that help you diagnose and like you know he's I know Vittorio has written like a tool I can't remember what it's called link in the show
我不知道我对比这些工具的推崇是否部分源于我是C++专家，而且这在很多时候已经是一种非常痛苦的体验。我是专家，但有时你会遇到一些……如果你在做前沿的东西，比如模板元编程或constexpr元编程，错误信息简直太糟糕了。真的，Vittorio Romeo和他的朋友们有一些关于帮助你诊断的工具的演讲，我知道Vittorio写过一个工具，我不记得叫什么了，链接在节目
notes but like it will it'll like collapse the nestedness of your like template metaprogramming compile time errors so that like you can parse them better. And every C++ developer that gets to a certain level knows that you develop a skill in parsing these. That like, oh, when you have the nested templates, you go all the way down and that's where the error will be and you just skip all that type information. And it's a painful experience
说明里，但它会折叠你那些模板元编程编译时错误的嵌套，这样你就能更好地解析它们。每个达到一定水平的C++开发人员都知道，你培养了一种解析这些错误的技能。比如，当你看到嵌套模板时，你直接跳到最底层，错误就在那里，你直接跳过所有那些类型信息。这是一种痛苦的体验。
and I have to become an expert in stuff that I don't wanna be an expert in. It's just like experience and I have to become an expert in stuff that I don't want to be an expert in it's just like I want to write code and I want to ship software or like, you know ship libraries and So much of the stuff like I think I mentioned in a different conversation that like the cognitive Load that I have to carry in my head as a C++ dev and so when a tool comes along that like it's you know, like Moses parting the Red Sea and being like you don't need to do any of that stuff. You can just like, you can all of that boilerplate
我必须成为我不愿成为的领域的专家。这就像……我必须成为我不愿成为的领域的专家，这只是……我只想写代码，只想发布软件，或者发布库。我认为我在另一场对话中提到过，作为一名C++开发人员，我脑子里必须承载的认知负荷太重了。所以当一个工具出现时，就像摩西分红海一样，告诉你：“你不需要做任何那些事情。”你可以把所有的样板代码……
and not just like documentation, unit tests, you know, and they say don't get it to write your unit tests, but like, do you know what, like writing a Google test, a G test or like a doc test, like there's so much scaffolding and then you can just go and like modify the test for the test case that you want. You want to definitely verify.
不仅仅是文档、单元测试，你知道，他们说不要让它写你的单元测试，但是，你知道吗，写一个Google Test，一个GTest或者doc test，有太多的脚手架工作了，然后你就可以直接去修改你想要的测试用例的测试。你想要明确地验证。
You're not just vibe coding your unit test, but do I really want to, oh, what's the macro for the top level thing, and there's the sub case thing, and if you're switching between unit test frameworks, they've all got different macros for stuff. Oh, that's right. You're not allowed to use a lambda inside a macro because it doesn't work that way, so you have to use function objects if you're doing... Anyway, it's just like the AI knows all of that, and you can hold your hand. use a lambda inside a macro because it doesn't work that way. So you have to use function objects if you're doing, anyway, it's just like the AI knows all of that and you just,
你不仅仅是在凭感觉写单元测试，但我真的想吗？哦，顶层宏是什么？还有子用例的东西，如果你在不同的单元测试框架之间切换，它们都有不同的宏。哦，对了。你不允许在宏内部使用lambda，因为它不是那样工作的，所以如果你在做……总之，AI知道所有这些，它可以牵着你的手。在宏内部使用lambda，因为它不是那样工作的。所以如果你在做……总之，AI知道所有这些，你只需要……
you can hold your hand. It's a very lovely experience. And then every once in a while, you do end up having to smash it over the head with a bat, but like that's no more painful than what I was doing before. And so I wonder if people that are coming from like Ruby or Rust that like have much better tool chains and it's less painful,
你可以牵着你的手。这是一种非常可爱的体验。然后偶尔，你确实需要用棍子敲它的头，但这并不比我以前做的事情更痛苦。所以我怀疑那些来自Ruby或Rust的人，他们有更好的工具链，痛苦更少，
are they less willing to tolerate when the models don't do well? That was kind of a thought I had in my head. I think that that may be true. I think that that may be true, but then on the other hand, I think that for people writing lower level systems code, large language models tend to do a much poorer job. There's this community called GPU Mode, which is like a GPU kernel hacking community.
他们是否更不愿容忍模型表现不佳的情况？这是我脑子里产生的一个想法。我认为这可能是真的。我认为这可能是真的，但另一方面，我认为对于编写底层系统代码的人来说，大语言模型往往表现得更差。有一个叫GPU Mode的社区，是一个GPU内核黑客社区。
And one of the projects they've been working on recently is developing a better training set and model for writing CUDA kernels. And the reason for this is, and this was like as of like three months ago, these evaluations, but they did evaluations of like how did the state of the art models do it writing CUDA kernels. And I don't remember the exact numbers, but I think it was something like for like 70% of the test cases, the state of the art models could not even produce code that would compile. And of the 30% that did compile, only 5% would run.
他们最近正在进行的项目之一是开发更好的训练集和模型来编写CUDA内核。原因在于——这是大约三个月前的数据——他们对最先进的模型在编写CUDA内核方面的表现进行了评估。我不记得确切的数字，但我认为大概是70%的测试用例中，最先进的模型甚至无法生成能编译的代码。而在那30%能编译的代码中，只有5%能运行。
And of the 5% that would run, only 1% would run fast. So that's a pretty bad failure rate. Only 1% of the tests, the state of the art models could only get the correct code for 1% of the tests. And by correct code, I mean, the reason you're using the GPU is because you want it to go fast. So if the code's slow, you don't care. And so one thing that they started doing
而在那5%能运行的代码中，只有1%运行得快。所以这是一个相当糟糕的失败率。只有1%的测试，最先进的模型只能为1%的测试获得正确的代码。所谓正确的代码，我的意思是，你使用GPU的原因是因为你想要它运行得快。所以如果代码很慢，你就不会在意。所以他们开始做的一件事是
is they run a coding contest on their Discord, where they have coding challenges to write an optimal kernel for something. And the coding challenges are all just an exercise to collect data, to create a curated data set of what good kernels look like, so that they can train or do fine tuning on a model to teach it how to write good kernels. And what I'm getting at here is that if you're writing some lower level systems code, if you're writing like concurrent or parallel code or performance sensitive code, which
他们在Discord上举办编程竞赛，通过编程挑战来编写某种东西的最优内核。这些编程挑战只是为了收集数据，创建一个关于好的内核是什么样子的精选数据集，以便他们可以对模型进行训练或微调，教它如何编写好的内核。我想说的是，如果你在编写一些底层系统代码，如果你在编写并发或并行代码，或者性能敏感的代码，这
is often what you're doing if you're in C++, the models are not necessarily as good at that as they are as like, oh, I want a website for doing x, y, or z. And I think you actually have to do a little bit more hand holding to get them to write correct concurrent code or correct performance-oriented code. So it's interesting because it may mean that, well, yeah, the large-scale fundamentals mean that a lot of the painful parts of doing the C++,
通常是你使用C++时所做的事情，模型在这方面的表现不一定像“哦，我想要一个做X、Y或Z的网站”那样好。我认为你实际上必须多做一点手把手的工作，才能让它们写出正确的并发代码或正确的性能导向代码。所以这很有趣，因为它可能意味着，嗯，是的，大规模的基础意味着C++中许多痛苦的部分，
like error messages, et cetera, can be automated away. It may require a little bit more human intervention and somebody who's more senior and who understands what the correct code would look like to be able to get them to generate good results. Yeah, that's fair enough. I definitely have had that experience where when I'm coding CUDA C++ libraries, you really need to... The directions it wants to take you without guidance are typically not great. And even when you spell out what you like, a lot of times they don't do it.
比如错误信息等，可以被自动化消除。它可能需要更多的人工干预，需要一个更资深、了解正确代码应该是什么样子的人，才能让它们生成好的结果。是的，这很公平。我绝对有过那种经历，当我编写CUDA C++库时，你真的需要……它在没有指导下想带你走的方向通常并不好。即使你明确说明了你想要什么，很多时候它们也不会那样做。
I mean, I just gave that presentation the other day with Thrust where I was like, all right, there might be a single algorithm with the first word and second word of this algorithm name. And it still did not reach for that algorithm. It was like, okay, I'll call these two separate things. So a lot of times, yeah, you need the expertise to know what you want. But if you have that expertise, I still find it more pleasant. And I wonder like if it's a lot of people, they they love the craft of writing code. And so they just have no interest in a tool that is gonna do the writing for them. And I used to think that like, I loved writing code. I know I like it, but like, I don't know,
我的意思是，我前几天刚做了那个关于Thrust的演讲，我说：“好吧，这个算法名称的第一个词和第二个词可能是一个单一的算法。”但它仍然没有调用那个算法。它就像是：“好吧，我会把这两个分开调用。”所以很多时候，是的，你需要专业知识来知道你想要什么。但如果你有那种专业知识，我仍然觉得它更令人愉快。我想知道，是否很多人，他们热爱编写代码的工艺，所以他们对一个要替他们写代码的工具根本不感兴趣。我曾经认为我热爱编写代码。我知道我喜欢它，但是，我不知道，
these tools to me, I feel like maybe that's the thing is I do love and that's maybe it explains why all of my YouTube videos are on these simple little leak code problems where they give you the function definition and the return type and like all You have to do is implement the algorithm. I love doing that stuff. You know what cuz there's no cruft There's no ceremony. You're just it's purely writing the algorithm and I think that's the thing is I love That kind of coding so much of programming and software engineering is not that. It's scaffolding, it's ceremony, it's dealing with errors, it's documentation,
这些工具对我来说，我觉得也许这就是原因，我确实热爱……也许这就解释了为什么我所有的YouTube视频都是关于这些简单的LeetCode问题，它们给你函数定义和返回类型，你所要做的就是实现算法。我喜欢做那些事情。你知道为什么吗？因为没有冗余代码。没有仪式感。你只是纯粹地在写算法，我认为这就是原因，我太喜欢那种编程了。软件工程中太多的东西不是那样的。它是脚手架，是仪式感，是处理错误，是文档，
it's unit test framework like setup. It's becoming a second expert in another language called CMake in order to get your build system to work. And I remember before I had my white belt or whatever the second level belt in CMake was. It was so painful trying to get a project to build and to pull in something. Now it's not that bad because I got my blue belt or whatever belt. And also CMake has gotten a lot better in terms of the utilities they provide you. They've got whatever the CPM fetch thing and you just pointed it to GitHub. It's a lot better than it used to be. But just like, I guess my thing here is that like the part that I love about coding, I still get to do. And I can just ignore the other
是单元测试框架的设置。为了让你的构建系统工作，你得成为另一种叫CMake的语言的第二专家。我记得在我获得白带或者无论什么CMake二级带之前。试图让一个项目构建并引入某些东西是多么痛苦。现在没那么糟糕了，因为我拿到了蓝带或者无论什么带。而且CMake在他们提供的实用程序方面也变得好多了。他们有那个什么CPM fetch，你只需要把它指向GitHub。它比以前好多了。但只是，我想说的是，我热爱编程的那部分，我仍然可以做。我可以忽略剩下的
90%. I don't know. I'm just, I'm trying to figure out why people are so averse to this, what I think is like the best thing to happen in our careers. Well, and I mean, one, like to that point, one, you know, on this question of is is AI going to eat software jobs? It's not like we as an industry, you know, it's not like like software famously, you know, doesn't like ship on time. It's not like we as an industry have a great track record of delivering bug-free code on the deadline that we set out to achieve.
90%。我不知道。我只是在试图弄清楚为什么人们对这个我认为是我们职业生涯中发生的最棒的事情如此反感。嗯，我的意思是，关于这一点，关于“AI是否会吃掉软件工作”这个问题，并不是说我们作为一个行业……你知道，软件行业以“不能按时交付”而闻名。并不是说我们作为一个行业在按设定的截止日期交付无Bug代码方面有很好的记录。
Software projects tend to be over budget, late, and have a lot fewer features than we intended. So we could have a 10x increase in software engineering efficiency. If we had a 10x increase in software engineering efficiency, I don't know that it would necessarily mean that we would have fewer software engineers. It might just like or even fewer software projects. It might just mean that
软件项目往往超出预算、延期，并且功能比我们预期的要少得多。所以我们可以将软件工程效率提高10倍。如果我们能将软件工程效率提高10倍，我不确定这是否一定意味着我们会减少软件工程师。这可能只是意味着……或者甚至减少软件项目。这可能只是意味着
like, you know, we can deliver higher quality stuff. Yeah, that's fair enough. I mean, what is the when you when you're saying that it came to mind the what's his name? Dunkey videos or whatever is a YouTube comedian that kind of makes funny videos about Video games and he had one on GTA 6 which I think that's the I don't play GTA, but whatever it's one of the rock star games It's very hyped and it's it's been delayed like years in the day That was like the the the punchline of the video is like that the trailer came out and then he was like Whoa, look at look at the graphics. Well, look at the graphics on these graphics and it's just a very beautiful trailer Look at the graphics on these graphics and it's just a very beautiful trailer look at the graphics on this graphics and then he's like unfortunately we'll never be able to play it because it's like delayed until 2026 or whatever yeah anyway so yeah
我们可以交付更高质量的东西。是的，这很公平。我的意思是，当你这么说的时候，我想到了那个……叫什么来着？Dunkey视频还是什么的，是一个YouTube喜剧演员，他制作关于电子游戏的搞笑视频，他有一个关于GTA 6的视频，我想那是……我不玩GTA，但不管怎样，那是Rockstar的游戏之一。它被大肆宣传，而且已经延期了好几年。那视频的笑点就是预告片出来了，然后他说：“哇，看看这些图形。看看这些图形上的图形。”那是一个非常漂亮的预告片。看看这些图形上的图形，那是一个非常漂亮的预告片。看看这些图形上的图形，然后他说：“不幸的是，我们永远无法玩到它，因为它被推迟到2026年还是什么的。”是的，总之，是的。
it's yeah famously we our industry is not great for shipping things on time I mean like where is a Apple's intelligence like they still don't really have AI? Like what's going on? They're working on it. Well and it's it's I mean I think we had to keep in mind that the the models and the technologies that we have today are still pretty rudimentary and limited. I often get frustrated when dealing with Claude in cursor or any model that I'm using in cursor because it's like I'm working with a junior engineer but a junior engineer who never learns. Cursor rules, cursor rules, buddy.
是的，我们的行业以不能按时交付东西而闻名。我的意思是，苹果的智能在哪里？他们仍然没有真正的AI？发生了什么？他们正在研究它。嗯，我认为我们必须记住，我们今天拥有的模型和技术仍然相当初级和有限。我在Cursor中处理Claude或我在Cursor中使用的任何模型时，经常感到沮丧，因为这就像我在和一个初级工程师一起工作，但这个初级工程师从不学习。Cursor规则，Cursor规则，伙计。
Yeah. But I think that I think that things like cursor roles and all the other equivalents of cursor roles that other frameworks have are a crutch for for like a bigger problem. And the bigger problem is that we need to have AI systems that have a first class, long term memory that things where when I'm working with something, it learns over time. And where it doesn't decohere over time. Because the problem is, you can't have a single session with a model that just
是的。但我认为像Cursor规则以及其他框架拥有的所有等效功能，都是解决更大问题的拐杖。更大的问题是，我们需要拥有具有一流、长期记忆的AI系统，当我与某物一起工作时，它会随着时间的推移而学习。而且它不会随着时间的推移而解体。因为问题在于，你不能与一个模型进行单一的会话，它只是
goes on forever because eventually it gets too large and eventually there's too much context or stuff falls out of the context window and things start to decoherent. And OpenAI has some memory system. But as far as I can tell, it's basically where it's just like a tool where when you're in chatting, if you have memory turned on with OpenAI and you're chatting with one of their models
永远持续下去，因为最终它变得太大，最终会有太多的上下文，或者东西会从上下文窗口中掉出来，事情开始解体。OpenAI有一些记忆系统。但据我所知，它基本上只是一个工具，当你聊天时，如果你在OpenAI中开启了记忆功能，并且你正在与他们的模型聊天，
and you tell the model something like, oh, I, you know, we like restaurants that don't have food that's deep fried or too salty. Like, you know, it has a tool where it'll be like store a fact that the user has this preference, or store a fact that the user's name is this, etc. And then it's got a database that has all those facts and it can go and pull those out. And maybe that's what the optimal memory looks like, and maybe that just needs to be matured a little bit. But I suspect that probably the next wave of big innovations that we'll see in models will be some big revolution in memory and in long-term memory.
你告诉模型一些事情，比如：“哦，我们喜欢没有油炸或太咸的食物的餐馆。”它有一个工具，它会像“存储一个事实，即用户有这种偏好，或者存储一个事实，即用户的名字是这个，等等。”然后它有一个包含所有这些事实的数据库，它可以去提取它们。也许这就是最佳记忆的样子，也许这只需要稍微成熟一点。但我怀疑我们将在模型中看到的下一波重大创新将是记忆和长期记忆方面的重大革命。
And that'll give us agents that have greater persistence and that learn from us over time and that sort of grow with us. Yeah, I mean, there's definitely like you learn the patterns of like you said, the first couple of days you were using it and then you kind of got you figured out it's like if you don't use cursor rules, you've probably found out that if you have a repo that has a building.md You shouldn't just ask it to build you should to be safe say build using at building.md And then it never fails with when you tell it where but if you don't tell it Depending on how it's feeling that day, you know, you might have 75% of the time
这将给我们带来具有更大持久性、随着时间推移向我们学习并与我们一起成长的代理。是的，我的意思是，肯定有像你说的，你学习了模式，最初几天你使用它，然后你弄清楚了，就像如果你不使用Cursor规则，你可能已经发现，如果你有一个包含building.md的仓库，你不应该只是要求它构建，为了安全起见，你应该说“使用@building.md构建”。然后当你告诉它在哪里时，它从不失败，但如果你不告诉它，根据它那天的心情，你知道，你可能有75%的时间
It does the right thing but usually what it ends up doing when it doesn't do it is it does something that doesn't work and then it greps the repo. Then it finds a building.md and then it goes. But it takes an extra 30 seconds for it to do the grepping and depending on what model you're using, it could be faster or slower. But you learn the golden path of one, just add a cursor rule.
它做对了，但通常当它做不对时，它做的事情不起作用，然后它会grep仓库。然后它找到一个building.md，然后它就成功了。但它需要额外30秒来做grep，根据你使用的模型，它可能更快或更慢。但你学会了黄金路径，第一，添加一个Cursor规则。
Or if you're not doing that, you just always point it at the building file. And it's true, why does a model after the one time in one session, does that not just like, what's the word, propagate to like every other session that when the first thing it should do behind the scenes when you ask it to build, if you're in a repository, is to go and check if there's a building.md
或者如果你不这样做，你总是把它指向构建文件。这是真的，为什么一个模型在一次会话中做了一次之后，那不会像……那个词是什么……传播到其他每一个会话，当你在一个仓库中要求它构建时，它在幕后应该做的第一件事就是去检查是否有building.md，
because obviously like there are the instructions there. I'm sure you could write a cursor rule telling the model to write cursor rules. You could write a cursor rule that says, when I tell you something that's a best practice that you should do in the future, write a cursor rule for that thing. I'm sure you could do something like that.
因为显然那里有说明。我相信你可以写一个Cursor规则，告诉模型去写Cursor规则。你可以写一个Cursor规则，说：“当我告诉你一些你应该在未来做的最佳实践时，为那件事写一个Cursor规则。”我相信你可以做类似的事情。
Or just have some feature built in that whenever you get interrupted by the user Because I imagine like I don't have it set up right now I still am typing all my commands But like I'm pretty sure I'm gonna set up so I can just start talking to this thing and like it's speech to text The other thing I was thinking is like so often my workflow now is because I'm using cloud for Sonic Which it usually takes you know 30 seconds to a couple minutes to maybe even a few minutes, depending on the task and how complex it is.
或者只是内置一些功能，每当你被用户打断时……因为我想象……我现在没有设置它，我仍然在输入我所有的命令。但我想我肯定会设置它，这样我就可以直接开始和这个东西说话，就像语音转文字一样。我还在想的另一件事是，我现在的工作流程通常是因为我正在使用Claude 3.5 Sonnet，它通常需要（你知道）30秒到几分钟，甚至几分钟，取决于任务及其复杂程度。
It takes some time. And so a lot of the times I'm like juggling, I'm juggling multiple things. And I tend not to do to like AI coding sessions. I'll be working on, you know, documentation. Yeah, no, no. Because the thing is, is like, I don't you're definitely not doing it in the same repo, or at least I'm not going to. So it's like.
它需要一些时间。所以很多时候我像是在杂耍，我在同时处理多件事。我倾向于不做AI编码会话。我会在处理……文档。是的，不，不。因为问题是，你绝对不会在同一个仓库里做，或者至少我不会。所以就像。
What you do is you create multiple repos. You create multiple checks out of the repos. There's a couple different techniques for doing this. Yeah, I don't like. I like my workflow. Maybe we should talk about that at some point, what the workflow. But currently, mine is I've got my single repository.
你做的是创建多个仓库。你创建多个仓库的检出。有几种不同的技术可以做到这一点。是的，我不喜欢。我喜欢我的工作流程。也许我们应该在某个时候谈谈那个工作流程。但目前，我的是我有一个单一的仓库。
I'm using Cursor, Cloud Force on it. I have the agentic window and I basically, I have everything that auto turns on but Nvidia doesn't let us do the total Yodel-O-Mo, but it'll let you go and search on the web and stuff. And so, you know, I've got it, I've got multiple monitors, you know, so I've got it on my main monitor. I ask it, give it quite a bit of detail.
我正在使用Cursor，Claude 3.5 Sonnet。我有代理窗口，我基本上……我有所有自动开启的东西，但Nvidia不让我们做完全的Yodel-O-Mo，但它会让你去网上搜索之类的。所以，你知道，我有多个显示器，所以我在主显示器上使用它。我问它，给它相当多的细节。
It sends off to work and then I'm gonna go start like, you know, working on some other task or task, putting them on some stack of things that I wanna do. But at times, you are waiting, it's like you would hope that it was a bit quicker so that I don't need, sometimes it's like five minutes and I'm like, I don't need five minutes.
它去工作了，然后我要去开始……你知道，处理其他任务，把它们放在我想做的事情的堆栈上。但有时，你在等待，你会希望它快一点，这样我就不需要……有时是五分钟，我想，我不需要五分钟。
I'm kinda going back and forth. What I'm thinking is, I spend a lot of time running, listening to podcasts. I would love to just like ambiently, and maybe this is like an unhealthy thing, but like I enjoy doing this stuff so much. I would like to ambiently be like just always talking and like working.
我有点来回切换。我在想的是，我花了很多时间跑步，听播客。我很想只是环境式地……也许这是一种不健康的事情，但我非常喜欢做这些事情。我想环境式地总是说话和工作。
So like if I'm going on an hour run or a two hour run, that's like two hours of lost productivity with GLaD. Where like, if it's, and if I tell it, like take a little bit more time, cause I don't want to every 30 seconds seconds it be interrupting my podcast and my run. But if I say, you know, check back in with me every five minutes, I would be so happy to like not even stop what I'm doing. You give me a pair of like the futuristic meta bands or whatever they're calling meta lenses. Like they're not here yet, but give me a pair of like, you know, Oakley sunglasses where I need a little bit of visual.
所以如果我要去跑一小时或两小时，那是两小时的生产力损失。如果我告诉它，多花点时间，因为我不想每30秒它就打断我的播客和跑步。但如果我说，每五分钟检查一下我，我会非常高兴，甚至不需要停下我正在做的事情。你给我一副像未来派的Meta眼镜或者他们称之为Meta镜片的东西……它们还没出来，但给我一副像Oakley太阳镜的东西，我需要一点视觉。
I can't just do it based off of whatever, but it gives me like, you know, in my little futuristic holographic thing, I stop running because, you know, I don't want to hit a bike or whatever. But you can imagine like walking around even while you're you're traveling, you're touring and just constantly making checking in and being like, OK, yeah, that's a great direction or no, the next step is to do this. And like how much time does it take to like vocalize and speak that? It's like 10 seconds, 20 seconds. And I just feel like that would be such a cool thing to do is like, you know,
我不能只根据任何东西来做，但它给了我……在我的小未来派全息图中，我停止跑步，因为（你知道）我不想撞到自行车什么的。但你可以想象，即使在你旅行、巡回演出时走来走去，不断地检查并说：“好的，是的，那是一个很好的方向”或者“不，下一步是做这个。”这需要多少时间来发声和说出来？大概10秒、20秒。我只是觉得那会是一件非常酷的事情，就像……
you're, you, you could then technically work and like just go for a walk. Maybe you're not even exercising on a daily basis, but now these tools like make it's like, whoa, I can still continue to absolutely take a meeting or go. It's like we already have a ton of flexibility because we both work remotely. But like I just I think it's going to completely change, you know, the way that we work and I don't know. It's yeah, I agree. And you know, for me, that's one of the really appealing things about it because I I've had all these ergonomic issues for years. I can't spend eight or 10 hours a day at the keyboard.
你可以在技术上工作，就像去散步一样。也许你甚至不是每天都在锻炼，但现在这些工具让它变得……就像，哇，我仍然可以继续绝对地参加会议或去……我们已经有了很大的灵活性，因为我们都在远程工作。但我只是……我认为它将完全改变我们工作的方式，我不知道。是的，我同意。而且你知道，对我来说，这是它真正吸引人的地方之一，因为我多年来一直有这些人体工程学问题。我不能每天在键盘前坐8到10个小时。
I can maybe spend three or four hours a day at the keyboard. Sometimes not even that. I've had issues for years. I figured eventually technology would solve this problem, but I thought it was going to be the brain chip. Fun fact, one of my childhood friends was like employee number 10 at Neuralink. So I probably had an in.
我可能每天只能在键盘前坐三四个小时。有时甚至不到那个时间。我多年来一直有这些问题。我想最终技术会解决这个问题，但我以为会是脑机芯片。有趣的事实是，我童年的一个朋友是Neuralink的第10号员工。所以我可能有一个内部渠道。
I probably could have got him to get one of the chips installed into my brain. But I figured that was going to be the thing, was that I was going to get the brain chip and then be able to interact directly with the computer. But I think it seems like the technological solution is going to be AI. It's going to be that eventually I just, maybe I'm at a keyboard,
我可能可以让他帮我把其中一个芯片植入我的大脑。但我以为那会是解决办法，我会得到脑机芯片，然后能够直接与计算机交互。但我认为技术解决方案似乎会是AI。最终我只是……也许我在键盘前，
but I'm not typing everything out. Maybe I'm typing out one prompter every five minutes or so and letting it work. Or I've been thinking about doing the speech to text thing so that I can go like completely keyboard free. I do I do find that like with the current like cursor UI like I do you know when I'm going and reviewing a diff or something or like I still have to you know go and like touch things or like you know selecting context is a little bit of a hassle so
但我不是在输入所有东西。也许我每五分钟输入一个提示词，然后让它工作。或者我一直在考虑做语音转文字的事情，这样我就可以完全不用键盘了。我确实发现，像目前的Cursor UI，当我回顾差异或类似的东西时，我仍然必须去触摸东西，或者选择上下文有点麻烦，所以
but I'm sure that there's ways like I'm sure that you could go a lot more compute like keyboard and mouse free if you wanted to which is like really exciting prospect to me so yeah I've been thinking about trying out the speech text although it may drive Ramona crazy to cheer me yelling at the the robot all day. Yeah, I mean, well, that's part of the reason I don't do it right now. But, you know, ideally, at some point we can have a bigger place and separate separate rooms, ideally on separate floors, because she also she works remotely. A lot of the times she has like virtual clinics and whatnot.
但我肯定有办法……我相信如果你愿意的话，你可以更多地摆脱键盘和鼠标，这对我来说是一个非常令人兴奋的前景。所以是的，我一直在考虑尝试语音转文字，尽管这可能会让Ramona发疯，因为我整天对着机器人大喊大叫。是的，我的意思是，嗯，这也是我目前不这样做的一部分原因。但是，你知道，理想情况下，在某个时候我们可以有一个更大的地方和单独的房间，理想情况下在不同的楼层，因为她也远程工作。很多时候她有虚拟诊所之类的。
But yeah, I mean, when I hear you say that, I worry because Shima gives me a hard time for being what's called a transhumanist, where, you know, we're there's a percentage of the tech bros that are super happy about the future of, you know, integrating and augmenting our intelligence with like hardware. And I posted a tweet a week ago that I asked a chat GPT to summarize like the the timeline of AI like levels because I finished watching a movie called Mountainhead which is a kind of dystopic look at billionaires and how they're destroying the world with tech and anyways it was like we're currently at a and I artificial narrow
但是是的，我的意思是，当我听到你这么说时，我很担心，因为Shima因为我被称为“超人类主义者”而给我难堪，你知道，有一部分科技兄弟对未来感到非常高兴，你知道，用硬件整合和增强我们的智力。我一周前发了一条推文，我让ChatGPT总结了AI水平的时间线，因为我看完了一部叫《Mountainhead》的电影，这是一种对亿万富翁以及他们如何用技术摧毁世界的反乌托邦式的观察，总之，就像我们目前处于ANI，人工智能，接下来是AGI，通用人工智能，之后是SI，超级智能，然后接下来的两个是超人类，就像与硬件整合，然后是后人类，就像把你的云上传到大脑，或者把你的大脑上传到云端。总之，当你谈论在脑子里植入芯片，这样你就可以和机器人说话时，我在那里就像是：“哦，伙计，那听起来太棒了。”我不想成为零号病人，但我知道我们的大多数受众是软件开发人员，但我确实想知道，因为我……有一个《纽约时报》的每日剧集，他们在评论一些事情。
intelligence next is a GI which is general after that is SI super intelligence and then the two after that are transhuman Which is like integrating with hardware and then posthuman which was like uploading your cloud to the brain Or uploading your brain to the cloud and anyways when you're talking about like getting a chip in your head So you can talk to the robots. I'm there like being like, oh man, that's just sounds so awesome Like I don't want to be I don't want to be patient zero but I and I know most of our audience is software developers, but I do wonder, like, is the, because I, there was a New York Times daily episode where they were commenting on some stuff.
他们的观点是，像我们这样的人在道德上是破碎的，我们不关心社会。这就像，我绝对关心社会，但我只是……为什么我们不关心社会。这就像我绝对关心社会。但我只是……为什么我们应该在自己周围画一个小盒子，关于我们是什么，或者应该或不应该，你知道，像……我不知道。也许我没有正确地表达这一点，但这只是……
And they were, their view with people like us is that we are broken morally, and that we're, we don't care about society. And it's like, I definitely care about society, but I also just like, why should we don't care about society. And it's like I definitely care about society. But I also just like why should we put a little box around us of like what we are or like should or should not, you know, like like do I don't know. Maybe I'm not articulating that correctly, but it's just like
并不是我不关心社会。只是我们生活在一个由我们的历史定义的世界里，人们很难想象未来会是什么样子。是的。是的，我的意思是，我认为通常当我们有伟大的科学进步或生产力上的巨大进步时，是的，就像工业革命，有很多负面影响，
it's not that I don't care about society. It's just like we live in a world that's defined by like our history and it's just hard for people to fathom what the future could look like. Yeah. Yeah, I mean, I think generally when we've had great scientific advancements or great advancements in productivity, yeah, like the industrial revolution, there were lots of downsides,
并不是我不关心社会。只是我们生活在一个由历史所定义的世界里，人们很难想象未来会是什么样子。是的。是的，我的意思是，我认为通常当我们取得伟大的科学进步或生产力上的巨大进步时，比如工业革命，确实有很多负面影响，
like children losing arms in factories, like stuff like that. It's not all good, but I think on the whole, great advances in technology have improved quality of life for humanity. I mean, I think you look at quality of life today versus 200 years ago, I think it's hard to argue that things aren't better now. You know, that doesn't mean that all the technological advancements have only been used for good or have only had good outcomes. And I don't mean just to suggest that the positive outcomes justify bad stuff that's
比如工厂里失去手臂的孩子，诸如此类的事情。这并不全是好事，但我认为总的来说，技术的巨大进步改善了人类的生活质量。我的意思是，看看今天的生活质量与200年前相比，我认为很难说现在的情况没有变好。你知道，这并不意味着所有的技术进步都只被用于善途或只有好的结果。我并不是想暗示积极的结果就能证明那些在过程中发生的坏事是合理的。
happened along the way. And certainly there's lots of ways in which AI is being used or will be used that may harm people. Things like surveillance, it certainly could be something that could become a tool of nefarious actors in various countries that do not enjoy the rights that our two countries have. But I mean, I think on the whole, it's hard to imagine that this won't be good for society unless you're of the perspective
当然，人工智能的使用方式有很多种，或者未来会被使用的方式可能会伤害到人们。比如监控，这当然可能成为某些国家不法分子的工具，这些国家的人民并没有享受到我们两国所拥有的权利。但我的意思是，我认为总的来说，很难想象这对社会不是一件好事，除非你持有某种观点，
that you believe that P-Doom is likely. And that, you know, it's just hard for me to imagine how that scenario plays out because technology is, at the end of the day, very, very brittle. And it would have to be not so brittle to really be a threat to us. But I also feel like it's almost impossible to control the development of AI. If we as a society decided that we weren't going to build AI because it was too dangerous, I don't know how we could possibly control that. Because it's not like, look at nuclear weapons. Nuclear weapons are something where- I was literally just thinking the same thing in my head.
即你认为“人工智能末日论”（P-Doom）很可能会发生。你知道，我很难想象那种情景会如何上演，因为归根结底，技术是非常、非常脆弱的。它必须变得不那么脆弱，才能真正对我们构成威胁。但我也觉得，控制人工智能的发展几乎是不可能的。如果我们作为一个社会决定不开发人工智能，因为它太危险了，我不知道我们怎么可能控制得住。因为这不像……看看核武器。核武器是那种……我刚才脑子里想的也是同样的事情。
You like for nuclear weapons, there's a specific set of physical materials that you have to control access to, um, uh, to create them from being created. And like, that's something that like, you can, you can monitor and you can observe, um, uh, and you know, detect through, through satellites to some degree. and detect through satellites to some degree. And even with all that, we've only had like an okay track record of, you know, of keeping new countries from developing nuclear weapons. I mean, look at current events, and look at events from, you know, past 10 to 20 years with North Korea.
对于核武器，有一套特定的物理材料，你必须控制对它们的获取，呃，以防止它们被制造出来。这是一种你可以监控、观察，并在一定程度上通过卫星探测到的东西。即使有这一切，我们在防止新国家开发核武器方面的记录也只能说是尚可。我的意思是，看看当前的事件，再看看过去10到20年里朝鲜发生的事件。
AI is not like that. To develop AI, you just need like some dude in their basement who has computers and, okay, maybe you need access to large quantities of compute to really do it. And so maybe there's an argument that that there's a similar like material constraint, but I don't think we're going to, like, you know, burn all the data centers down entirely, because we need them for other things. And if you don't get rid of all the data centers, or control tightly control all the data centers, I don't see how you can, how you can keep people from developing AI. And so it seems like it's a futile effort to try to put regulatory guardrails on it.
人工智能不是那样的。要开发人工智能，你只需要一个地下室里有电脑的家伙，好吧，也许你需要获得大量的计算资源才能真正做到。所以也许有人会争辩说存在类似的物质限制，但我不认为我们会把所有的数据中心都烧掉，因为我们需要它们做其他事情。如果你不除掉所有的数据中心，或者严格控制所有的数据中心，我不明白你怎么能阻止人们开发人工智能。所以，试图在上面设置监管护栏似乎是一项徒劳的努力。
And in terms of like technical guardrails of things like aligning models and stuff like that, it seems like we get really mixed results right now. So part of my perspective is like, if the AI is going to kill us, then it's inevitable that we'll develop the AI that will kill us. There's not really much that we as society can do to stop that. So if it's going to turn us all into paper clips, then we're sort of doomed anyways. And if it's not going to, then that's great. And so there's not much for us to do because it's either inevitable doom or we're going to be fine. I mean, I would never word it that way because I'm sure there's some listeners, but I do completely agree. I've always said that we were born arguably at the perfect time because most AI folks,
至于对齐模型之类的技术护栏，目前看来我们的结果非常参差不齐。所以我的一部分观点是，如果人工智能要杀死我们，那么我们注定会开发出杀死我们的人工智能。作为社会，我们能做的阻止它的事情并不多。所以如果它要把我们都变成回形针，那我们反正也注定要完蛋了。如果它不会，那太好了。所以我们没什么可做的，因为要么是不可避免的末日，要么我们会没事的。我的意思是，我永远不会那样表达，因为我相信会有一些听众，但我完全同意。我一直说我们出生在可以说是完美的时代，因为大多数人工智能领域的人，
they say that if the singularity is going to happen in the paperclip, you know, some version of that scenario happens, it's going to be roughly 2050. Some people are saying sooner now because they didn't realize things would accelerate this quickly. But the point being is that like, you know, we're in our 30s, 2050, another 20 years, hit our 50s, you know, we were alive, we got to see it all, and then it could end, but it's like, we are not going to stop that. Like, whether, you know, it's like there's all these different agreements globally, there's always one country that's like, no, no, no, you guys do that, but I'm going to go ahead
他们说如果奇点要发生，回形针那种情景的某个版本发生，那大约会在2050年左右。有些人现在说得更早，因为他们没意识到事情会加速得这么快。但重点是，你知道，我们现在30多岁，到2050年还有20年，那时我们50多岁，你知道，我们活着，我们见证了这一切，然后它可能会结束，但就像，我们是不会阻止它的。无论，你知道，全球有各种各样的协议，总有一个国家会说，不，不，不，你们做吧，但我打算继续
and like, you know, make money and we're going to and so that like there's no there's no stopping this and yeah so I kind of agree like if it's gonna happen it's gonna happen but I don't think it's gonna happen and I just think it's gonna like I used to say when I was a bit younger that I actually think I thought it was suboptimal that we the time we got born like imagine if you knew that planes were like like traveling by plane was a thing and you were born like in the 1860s and then like you only at the tail end did you start to see it and then like it became like you weren't able to travel unless if you hopped on a boat that's a whole thing it's like you don't get to go and so now the planes I
赚钱，我们要……所以这根本无法阻止。是的，所以我有点同意，如果它要发生，它就会发生，但我不认为它会发生。我只是觉得……我年轻的时候常说，我其实认为我们出生的时间点不是最优的。想象一下，如果你知道飞机旅行是存在的，而你出生在1860年代，然后你只在最后阶段才开始看到它，然后它变得……除非你跳上一艘船，否则你无法旅行，那是一整套麻烦事，所以你没法去。所以现在飞机我
have the same view of like technologies that we don't exist at some point you're going to have like shoes that give you the ability to fly. And it's like, I can't believe I live in the time where I don't get to fly with my shoes, you know? It's like, there's some equivalence of that, that is it shoes that make you fly? Is it your ability to teleport from one place to another? It's some crazy thing that we can't fathom
对技术也有同样的看法，我们现在不存在，但在某个时候，你会有能让你飞行的鞋子。就像，我不敢相信我生活在一个我不能穿着鞋子飞行的时代，你知道吗？就像，有某种等价的东西，是让你飞行的鞋子吗？是你从一个地方传送到另一个地方的能力吗？那是某种我们无法理解的疯狂事物，
that at the tail end of my life, I'm gonna start to see the beginnings of beginnings of and I'm gonna be like oh damn like it would have been good if I had been born like 50 years later so that I could do that and I feel that like AI potentially is that thing that's gonna unlock all this stuff and you know potentially people are gonna be able to live like way longer and anyway I don't know I I guess part of my thinking here is that I think that, I do think that, like almost any technology, AI and mistakes with AI will likely cause damage
在我生命的尽头，我将开始看到它的萌芽，我会说，哦该死，如果我晚出生50年就好了，这样我就能做到那些事了。我觉得人工智能可能就是那种能解锁所有这些东西的东西，你知道，人们可能能够活得更久。总之，我不知道，我想我在这里的部分想法是，我认为，我确实认为，像几乎任何技术一样，人工智能以及人工智能的错误很可能会对社会和社区造成损害。
to society and communities. I think it's more likely that this happens not through ill intent, but just through bugs and accidents. In the same way that there have been various disruptions of the internet and of the stock market by bugs in tech. There have been things like the flash crashes from like algorithmic trading companies that
我认为这更有可能不是出于恶意，而仅仅是由于漏洞和事故。就像互联网和股市曾因技术漏洞而受到各种干扰一样。比如算法交易公司曾出现过闪崩，
had a bug in their algorithm, trading companies that you know had a bug in their algorithm something like that. I think that for AI to present a real existential threat to us you need a few things. One you would need an actual artificial general intelligence which we're still pretty far from I think. I still think that that's something that we won't see for five to 10 years. You'd need that. And it would need to be a really a persistent thing that is like an ongoing and long running process, right?
他们的算法里有漏洞，交易公司你知道，他们的算法里有漏洞，诸如此类。我认为人工智能要对我们构成真正的生存威胁，你需要几样东西。第一，你需要一个真正的人工通用智能，我认为我们离那还很远。我仍然认为那是我们未来5到10年内不会看到的东西。你需要那个。而且它需要是一个非常持久的东西，是一个持续运行的过程，对吧？
And it would need to be incredibly resilient. If it's a thing that lives solely on the internet, I don't know that that is sufficient to present a threat to us because I, I actually might disagree with that. You know, one time in Toronto, payment systems went offline for like four hours and it caused like pandemonium. Like, you know, you couldn't go to a bank to withdraw money. Like you couldn't. Everyone was freaking out. And it was it was like four hours of not having credit card things working.
而且它需要极其强大。如果它只是一个仅仅存在于互联网上的东西，我不知道这是否足以对我们构成威胁，因为我……我实际上可能不同意这一点。你知道，有一次在多伦多，支付系统离线了大约四个小时，导致了混乱。就像，你知道，你不能去银行取钱。就像你不能。每个人都吓坏了。那就像是四个小时信用卡无法使用。
And like the payment systems were just all down. It was nuts. But there's a big difference between pandemonium and the robot turning this on into paper clips, right? Yes, but you could imagine a world where with deep fake and misinformation and shutting down the internet, it would just lead to absolute anarchy. And it wouldn't be the end of the world, but the amount of damage that it could cause would be like
支付系统全都瘫痪了。这太疯狂了。但混乱和机器人把我们变成回形针之间有很大的区别，对吧？是的，但你可以想象一个世界，随着深度伪造、错误信息和互联网关闭，这只会导致绝对的无政府状态。这不会是世界末日，但它可能造成的损害程度会是……
yeah, a word bigger than massive. I don't need like, you know, completely like I can imagine. I can imagine substantial damage, but not like existential end of human life damage. Oh, yeah. Yeah, not existential. But like, yeah, there'd be millions and millions of people that died. For existential damage, I think you would need to have a persistent artificial general intelligence that has a physical presence, which means that it would need to have robots
是的，一个比“巨大”更严重的词。我不需要……我可以想象。我可以想象巨大的损害，但不是那种人类生命终结的生存性损害。哦，是的。是的，不是生存性的。但确实会有成百上千万的人死亡。对于生存性损害，我认为你需要一个具有物理存在的持久人工智能，这意味着它需要有机器人
or drones or control of physical resources. And it would probably have to have control of those resources in multiple resilient communication mechanisms that can't be disrupted by the various militaries and governments of the world. And that actually seems like that's a pretty high bar to clear to me at least. I just realized like this conversation started off like an hour ago being like, yeah, like, I don't get why people aren't excited about clock four.
或无人机，或对物理资源的控制。而且它可能必须在多种无法被世界各国军队和政府破坏的弹性通信机制中拥有对这些资源的控制权。这对我来说似乎是一个相当高的门槛。我刚才意识到，这段对话大约在一小时前开始时还在说，是的，我不明白为什么人们对GPT-4不感到兴奋。
And like, you know, I think it's really changing the way the workflow is. Is it because they're worried about jobs? And now we're talking about like, what are the actual parameters that would need to exist in order for the AI, the artificial general or super intelligence to wipe us out? Yeah. I mean, like the...
而且，你知道，我认为它确实改变了工作流程。是因为他们担心工作吗？而现在我们正在谈论，为了让人工智能、通用智能或超级智能消灭我们，需要存在哪些实际参数？是的。我的意思是，那个……
I do think that like, if you have like a scary like rogue model, some sort of scary persistent rogue model that escaped containment and was like out there on the internet, I, my guess would be that world governments have a greater ability to turn off the pipes of the internet and control things than we might imagine. Yeah, yeah. I mean, that's the case. A lot of countries, they can just turn on and off the internet whenever they want, right? Yeah. I mean, like, you know, it would be pandemonium, but, you know, and then... Yeah, yeah. If you were talking about existential, like, end of life, like humans don't exist,
我确实认为，如果你有一个可怕的流氓模型，某种逃离了控制并在互联网上游荡的可怕的持久流氓模型，我的猜测是，世界各国政府关闭互联网管道和控制事物的能力比我们想象的要大。是的，是的。我的意思是，确实如此。很多国家，他们想什么时候关掉互联网就能关掉，对吧？是的。我的意思是，你知道，那会是混乱，但，你知道，然后……是的，是的。如果你说的是生存性的，比如生命终结，比如人类不存在，
yeah, that's definitely not what would happen. There would be a bunch of folks that survived. It wouldn't be a good situation, but like, yeah, we would be able to rebuild for some definition of the word rebuild. Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at adspthepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a GitHub discussion
是的，那绝对不会发生。会有很多人幸存下来。那不会是一个好的局面，但是的，我们能够重建，无论“重建”这个词的定义是什么。请务必查看这些节目说明，无论是在您的播客应用程序中还是在adspthepodcast.com上，以获取我们今天提到的任何内容的链接，以及GitHub讨论的链接，
where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。我们希望您喜欢并祝您有愉快的一天。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。